so I've set this channel up because I
find things like self-improvement
bodybuilding brain training all of this
super interesting and there wasn't much
content like this on youtube or on the
web in general so I thought I'd share it
with you guys and hopefully you'd find
it interesting but what I really love is
when some messages me and says that
something I've said has really helped
them which I didn't really massively
expect to be honest because most of my
videos about training like spider-man or
becoming Batman I only enjoyed one
comment someone left on my be like
Batman video where they were like thanks
a lot I'm Batman now um anyways I really
love it when something I share helped
somebody so in this video I'm going to
share the technique or the knowledge
that I think has been the most helpful
to me personally as well as a lot of
people that I know it's called CBT and
it's in many ways the best kind of brain
training that I know it's how to become
limitless without the pill
so I studied psychology at University
and that's where I learned about all
this stuff that's why I'm always talking
about neuroscience and the kind of
nervous system in relation to training
it's that's my area of interest
CBT was one of the concepts that most
appealed to me and made a lot of
intuitive sense this is a
psychotherapeutic
technique meaning that it's a form of
therapy similar to psychoanalysis or
behavioral therapy is used to treat a
range of psychological disorders such as
phobias anxiety disorders
obsessive-compulsive disorder and it
stands for cognitive behavioral therapy
which will make sense in a moment when
we get to it it's kind of a combination
between cognitive psychology and
behavioral therapy so normally CBT is
used to address psychological issues
however I believe it can be much more
than that I could believe it can be used
to become better than well it can be
used to increase your productivity your
focus your concentration how to get into
a flow state to help you be more
positive to help you sleep better it's
great for overcoming insomnia to help
you get more strength in the gym more
mind muscle connection all of these
things and I think it is actually really
untapped in terms of its potential and
talked a little bit about some of my
ideas in that regard towards the end but
we look at it in the context of treating
mental illness because that's the
easiest way to understand it so let's
say that you have a phobia of heights
you go and see a psychoanalyst this is
an old school psychologist they'll tell
you it might stem from something in your
childhood a repressed feeling or emotion
something you've forgotten maybe the way
your parents raised you they'll talk to
you go and really in depth they'll do
inkblot tests analyze your dreams and
try and dig deep to the roots of your
unconscious problems that's falling a
little bit out of favor although some
people still use it and it still has its
merits then you might go to a behavioral
therapist if that didn't work and they
would basically train you to not be
afraid of those Heights by just going to
Heights gradually getting higher and
higher and making the experience less
horrible by associating it with nice
things maybe eating sweets maybe
thinking happy thoughts and this would
eventually prevent you from being afraid
of heights but it's all about training
it's all about interacting with the
world while CBT says is that it's not
just the experiences that cause the
phobia but the way you're thinking about
them and so it's going to try
and change the way you think about
Heights so let's say that you're afraid
of heights what might be causing that
fear well a behavioral therapist would
say that you once experienced the height
in an under negative circumstances you
were very afraid and this caused a
association between that height and the
fear or maybe you watch somebody else
fall from a height or maybe you were up
high a lot in a negative context
likewise the psychoanalyst would say
that you had a bad experience in
childhood that you repressed like I said
but the cognitive behavioral therapist
would point out that some people are
afraid of heights and they've never even
been high up so how does this happen and
it's all up here because you can
rehearse that situation in your mind you
can think about being high up even when
you're not high up and that can make you
scare me create the Association you can
wire those neurons together if you've
watched my video on neuron
neuroplasticity you can wire those new
arms together even without having to
experience it because when we imagine
doing something to our brain it's no
different from actually doing it similar
brain areas fire as though you're
engaging in the action so you can create
a vivid enough experience in your mind's
eye that you become afraid of heights
and more than that you reaffirm that
fear by going high up and then thinking
bad things if you go up high say you're
going to look at a view on a mountain if
you're someone who's afraid of heights
you might find yourself thinking damn
what if I jump or what if I fall if I
slip or you might find yourself
imagining plummeting to the ground and
all these things are making you much
more scared than if you didn't think
those things if you thought more
positive things like what most people
don't fall or I'm standing far away from
the edge or who has ever tripped to that
far you know we wouldn't be allowed up
here if it was unsafe all that stuff if
I died I'd know nothing about it it
wouldn't even be that bad so you need to
replace those negative thoughts and
associations with positive ones by
changing the way that you think and like
I say this can affect many different
areas of your life not just Heights so
for instance if you're someone who
struggles socially to speak confidently
to people then you might think huh if I
speak up now in this group it was gonna
laugh at me they're gonna think what I
said was stupid then they're gonna I'm
not gonna take me seriously I'm it's
just best not to do it and you start to
get that physiological response as
though you were already speaking in
public you're shaking you're nervous
you're sweating and you haven't
down anything and these are all your
friends they don't care and if they do
TZ it's just because they love you so
you need to replace those negative
thoughts and this could make you much
more confident you start to see yourself
improving your experience in life twice
in my life changing the way I think
about things has helped me and I'll talk
about that in a moment so now you know
the problem what techniques does
cognitive behavioral therapy recommend
you use in order to address the problem
it recommends you use something called
cognitive restructuring which is as cool
as it sounds you're basically
reprogramming your own mind the first
part of this is mindfulness it's being
more aware of your own thoughts you can
do this through mindful meditation which
means you're meditating but not trying
to block out thoughts you're just trying
to reflect on thoughts and you can do it
through journal keeping just writing a
journal you can do it just through
simply being more aware of what you're
doing throughout the day and mindfulness
in itself has a ton of great benefits
because we do all sorts of things on
autopilot we think and act in ways that
we're not conscious of here's a little
experiment to help you see how much you
do without thinking about it try and
count the number of times today or
tomorrow that you sit down and stand up
from a chair sounds really simple right
I bet you you'll forget to do it after
the second time you'll do it once you'll
do it after this one you might even not
do it that time
and then you'll forget that's how
unmindful we are also distracted by
other things so be mindful notice your
thoughts write them down if it helps and
realize think about why is it that I'm
afraid of heights that are afraid of
speaking in public that I procrastinate
that I can't sleep write these things
down what's actually going through your
mind often if you're very sad you might
find that you can even get to the basis
of it I really have the devil's in a
proper funk I was really miserable
because I was meant to be seeing my
family I wasn't able to and I was just
miserable all day and I was like why am
i miserable
who's this helping and I realized that
deep down I was miserable because I felt
like I deserved sympathy and if I acted
miserable people would be nice to me
except my wife was already being nice to
me there's no one else in the house so
it's a kind of natural reaction and when
I realized that I was like what doesn't
benefit me and I'm gonna see them later
I can call them on the phone and I was
able to be much happier so simply just
being mindful of your own thoughts can
help a great deal but then we're going
to try and change those thoughts with
cognitive restructuring one way we do
this is with something called thought
challenging
thought challenging means you simply
look at what it is that you're worried
about or that's holding you back and
then you challenge it you say how likely
is this to be a problem so let's say
that it's public speaking you're afraid
of if you're going to go and give a
speech and you've assessed what it is
that you're worried about worried that
people are gonna laugh at you if you say
something wrong or if you stutter now
we're going to use thought challenging
to assess how realistic that concern is
and here's the reality most people
aren't gonna laugh in you if you stutter
onstage most people are much more
compassionate than that if you laugh at
something because having a hard time on
stage you're an ass we've all been there
at the same time does it really matter
no you don't know these people you're
not going to see them again probably so
stutter if you like and as soon as you
relax and you stop worrying about
stuttering then you don't stutter
anyways so you have to help yourself to
come to terms with that fear and realize
it's not so bad
likewise you can use this to overcome
fears of achieving certain goals Tim
Ferriss in the book the 4-hour workweek
talks about fear setting which basically
means that you you make your fears and
concerns concrete the things are holding
me back from taking chances in life so
say you want to start your own business
but you keep putting it off you write
down the reasons that you're not the
reasons you're afraid and then you
assess each one on how realistic it is
and you look at plans for how you'd
better get those things if they did go
wrong say for instance I would leave my
job I'd have no money I'd end up on the
streets and my wife would leave me well
how about this you don't leave your job
until you've got a working business
model so you know it works and then you
transition out maybe go part-time first
so that's not really gonna be an issue
you've probably got enough savings to
last for about two months you're
probably not completely unable to find
more work if this goes sour
you've probably got parents who've
helped you out who you could live with
your wife probably isn't gonna leave you
for chasing your dreams if so then you
know maybe you need to rethink your
relationship again a lot of the fears
that hold us back and not that realistic
and by assessing them by making them
concrete and realizing that we can
overcome them and then the other one you
can use the other form of cognitive
restructuring is hypothesis testing and
here what you're gonna do is not just
think about the thing that's holding you
back you're actually going to get out
there and try doing it and see that
you're wrong so for instance if you're
worried about speaking in public because
you think you're gonna stuff in people
will laugh at you you're going to speak
in public and you purposefully stutter
you
purposefully leave long gaps in between
what you're saying and you just wait and
people will wait with you because
they're sympathetic and once you've done
that a couple of times and you've
realized it's not so bad then you can
relax
so by assessing your thoughts writing
down what's holding you back and testing
them you can overcome all sorts of
negative ideas and at the same time
think it's a good idea to include
visualization in this in some regard
because as I've said before when you
visualize something your brain
essentially thinks you're doing that
thing you you light up the same brain
areas and as we know neurons that fire
together wire together so if you keep
imagining falling off something and of
course you create the association that
Heights dangerous but if you vividly
imagine you're standing far back from
the edge of a cliff or a mountain then
you can become more relaxed and start to
remove that negative Association check
out my video on embodied cognition to
understand just how much visualization
can play a role in the way we think it
in fact explains how we understand our
language even to me embodied cognition
is the missing link between behaviorism
and cognitive behavioral therapy because
it explains how simply by thinking
something we're able to create the new
associations as they we were practicing
them for real really all of this also
demonstrates you just how much of your
physiological reaction and your emotions
are impacted by your thoughts and not
just by what's actually happening by
your visualisation an example I you like
to use for this is that you're out
camping with your friends and you hear
rustling in the bush you're in the
African savannah so you suspect this
might be a lion a tiger a snake
something dangerous what's gonna happen
your heart rate is gonna increase you're
gonna start sweating you're gonna go
cold you're gonna feel nervous and
you're gonna have that reaction as
though something terrible is happening
even before it's happened you're ready
for anything but at the same time you're
anxious you're nervous you're struggling
to focus but if you were to then
discover that it was just a kitten or
that it was your friend having a laugh
then you'd instantly relax because now
you know you're not in danger so it
wasn't the fact that there was a tiger
there wasn't the reality that made you
have that reaction it was your
interpretation it was your internal
experience and here's the thing we
imagine lions all around us all the time
we imagine that things are worse than
they are all the time you think that
your boss is gonna fire you because
you're late no he's not it's illegal to
do that you think that your partner's
going to leave you
cuz you forgot to text no she's not
she's chill she's cool or he's cool
pointers we over blow these things we
make things worse in our heads and it
minx that makes us less productive and
makes us less focused and makes us less
happy makes us less efficient in general
so being more conscious of our thoughts
and learning how to control them and
change those negative ones can help a
great deal
[Music]
CBT also involves learning a whole bunch
of different tools and skills things
like breathing techniques things like
meditation that you can use to address
the physiological signs and the thoughts
when you notice them so for instance if
you notice your heart rate getting
higher
CBT therapist a cognitive behavioral
therapist will teach you to breathe to
calm down
to slow your heart rate we've talked
about techniques you can use things like
box breathing in order to achieve that
they'll also use things like biofeedback
which means looking at how your heart
mate heart rate increases under certain
circumstances and how it decreases under
well others I'm pointing on my wrist
because you might use a fitness track to
do this for instance and then you learn
more about how to control your own
physiologic physiology and of course
this is very interesting to any
biohacker
this is something that we already do it
just makes sense to do it in this
context so I said I'll talk about how
CBT helped me personally and maybe this
will help it to help you as well and to
see how it could improve your own life
so one example is when I was younger I
had a kind of weird thing where I
struggled with ping in men's urinals a
little bit embarrassing apparently I'm
sharing now the reason I was afraid it
turned out when I applied a bit of
mindfulness was that I thought that if I
couldn't we I'd be standing there and
then people would look at me like why is
there a dude hanging out in the toilet
not doing anything and they'd think I
was weird perv so every time I went to
go for a pee in a pub or something this
would be my concern if people see me
just stood there they'll think I'm a
pervert and I won't be out of weed
because I'm so nervous then I couldn't
we because I was so nervous so I always
ended up peeing in the cubicles which
obviously meant queueing which obviously
wasn't very convenient it was weird and
I realized this wasn't healthy I needed
to overcome it so what I ended up
realizing was that a no one's gonna
think that because most people won't be
in there long enough and if they are
they're in the same condition as me so
and they're in no position to think that
and be they're probably all drunk if I'm
at the pub so they're not even gonna
notice see I don't care if they think
I'm weird perfect then that's fine as
long as I don't call the police then I'm
happy for a stranger to think that I'm
checking out his tackle so I just
reminded myself of this I would think it
was those in the toilet it doesn't
matter just cool and then I
at the same time practice standing there
for longer hypothesis testing to ensure
that it really wasn't that bad nothing
bad become a bit of course it didn't and
today you have no problem being in
public urinals a win for Adam another
example of when it helped me was when I
had troubles getting to sleep in the end
my mum pointed out to me that the
problem might be that I was trying too
hard to get to sleep and that the
solution was just to not try and sleep
but just try and rest because even when
you're lying down you're still resting
and it might not be as good as sleep but
it's still giving you some kind of
recovery and that's good enough and as
soon as I did that as soon as I took the
pressure off of getting to sleep I was
able to sleep because I was stressing
about not in game not getting to sleep
and that was raising my heart rate it
was putting me in a physiologically
aroused the mood I was looking at the
alarm clock saying 4 a.m. and getting
stressed out because at school the next
day but then by thinking I'm just lying
here I'm just chilling and that's fine
and I actually enjoyed chilling and as
soon as I started to just enjoy lying
there letting thoughts wash over me and
stop worrying about ways to get to sleep
and I fell asleep like a light and I
still come to this day so again that was
a way that CBT could be used to treat
insomnia and CBT is very effective at
treating insomnia in general I do still
have a phobia of stickers and I'm sure
there's a CBT way of getting over that
but I haven't tried that yet it's not so
much a failure I just find them really
gross I don't like looking at them I
find repulsive you've learned a lot
about me today yeah and see that he can
also be used in all sorts of ways to
improve your performance your efficiency
or productivity so in a Productivity
setting if you keep procrastinating you
might use a bit of mindfulness to try
and work out why you're procrastinating
and to you know find ways to give
yourself whatever it is you're looking
for maybe you're tired this is just
being more aware of your body maybe it's
the what you're doing you find boring
and you need to find ways to make it
more interesting just as you can make
things less important you can also make
things more important by associating
them with the goal that's at the end of
the line so for instance if you work on
a really boring project visualize and
imagine the adulation you'll get from
your client from your boss when you
complete that project and visualize you
know your successful future self who's
got a great career because you've worked
hard today and
get yourself to feel that way people use
CBT to overcome eating disorders and
also to help themselves with diets being
more aware of your thoughts can also
help you to be more focused and more
calm and collected when you're in a
fight when you're practicing martial
arts can help you to focus more on your
workouts in the gym and I've talked
about flow States and a lot of what we
discussed there was about changing where
you think and changing your
physiological response to situations so
that you're aroused but not anxious so
that you're alert but not wired and see
if you can also make you more social
more confident more effective networker
and entrepreneur so you'll make you
again more like Eddie Mora on NZT
because you're not because you're
charismatic and charming and relaxed
instead of anxious and nervous it can
help you work towards your goals as in
Big Easy as in the example of fear
setting from Tim Ferriss I have a friend
right now who's studying a coaching
course helping people achieve their
dreams and goals and that revolves
around CBT - so that's CBT in a nutshell
of course there's much more to it than
that and I'll talk about it again in the
future but this was just a quick
overview some ideas and hopefully it can
help you in some aspects of your own
life and of course if you do find any of
this useful and you have a serious
problem that I recommend going to see a
cognitive behavioral therapist and
they'll help you through all this
they'll teach you to use it properly if
you did fancy video then please leave a
like please share around that helps me
out immensely subscribe to the channel
for more like this hit the bell button
for notifications and stay tuned because
I've got tons more on the way I'll be
talking about how to get your dream job
online how to Train like an mi6 special
agent how to accelerate learning and
learn more topics all sorts of stuff
bodybuilding calisthenics if that all
sounds good then stay tuned thanks a ton
for watching and I'll see you next time
bye for now
own guys I've got an idea for a future
bio near video and it's gonna be on home
bat caves so bat cave in this definition
is either a home gym or home office
that's really cool that makes you feel
productive it helps you train maybe
you've got some cool workout equipment
in there some unique ideas maybe you've
got a really inspiring home office
design I'm gonna be sharing my home
office and my gym that I call the bio
lab partly because I'm being forced to
move into a different room so you'll
I'll be getting rid of this one it'd be
nice to commit it to memory on film but
I want to see yours as well so if you
guys head over to the Facebook page and
share a link to your or a photo to your
home gym or your productivity space we
got combined both and all the best ones
with your permission I'll share in that
video and we can look at all of our bat
caves and come up with cool ideas for
home productive workspaces and gyms and
yeah nerd out like that so if that
sounds cool then head over to the
Facebook page the link will be in the
description scroll down until you find
that topic I'll post about that and
that'll be there say again thanks Don
for watching and bye for now